hi everyone my name is Hannah before I
get started just a few quick things
about me first of all you can find me on
the Internet in case you want to contact
me my handle is usually at tech girl
wonder that's my little logo and fYI
ADIZ she her pronounce I work for a
company called carbon 5 we are a product
development agency we work with all
kinds of clients from small startups to
big enterprises and we help them turn
their ideas into working software
whatever that looks like we are hiring
and we're hire abaut and there's a whole
bunch of us right down there in case you
want to chat with us afterwards so yeah
lastly personal anecdote that's my dog
she can vouch for me that I'm alright so
you know I'm an okay person cool just
FYI there's gonna be no Q&A
unfortunately do you have about a full
40 minutes of content and but you could
submit stuff to the app and I will try
to answer it afterwards so yeah um this
is a talk about reactive programming and
specifically why I think it's a great
way to write front-end applications it's
in five parts so here we go
greetings to all of the legendary
children and welcome to the functional
reactive programming ball tonight the
category is what is a computer program
so a very important computer science
textbook that I refer to frequently
defines a computer program as a sequence
of instructions for performing a task
designed to solve specific problems and
I always tend to focus on the the phrase
sequence of instructions because it
makes me think about programs like
they're a to-do list right or if we were
to look at a different context like a
classroom you might imagine a program as
a lesson plan a series of things you're
going to do to get to your objectives
but are these really the right metaphors
so if you're writing command-line tools
they might be but if you are writing
front-end programs which is what this
talk
about there's maybe a better metaphor
that I think of and that's that's this
the unruly classroom because front-end
programs are basically they don't run
sequentially at all they're completely
dependent on user input and they're
dependent on servers that you're talking
to and they're based and you're
constantly getting interrupted when you
do front-end programming and that's
really it in my opinion I think that
interruptions effectively are the heart
of front-end programming so I'd like to
talk briefly about a couple patterns
we've used for dealing with
interruptions in front-end programming
over the course of UI development so the
the first pattern the very first one I
ever interacted with was something
called the global event bus and the
global of it and the first kind of
programming I ever did was a DOS game
programming so this is see you don't
need to know C to understand what's
going on here hopefully but what you
would do in a DOS game is you could
effectively override the bios of your
computer a very low level kind of piece
of software and completely take over the
keyboard or the mouse of your computer
and then you would write some code to
take what was going on on your computer
what was being typed into the keyboard
and maybe stored in a buffer or
something oops sorry
gotta get used to this presentation
remote oops sorry
you drop thee ah no matter how much I
practice I always have a moment like
that that's okay anyway
so yeah so here would be like your
keyboard handler and then the rest of
your your program would essentially be a
giant loop you'd be looping effectively
forever until a user did something like
a quit and and then in the middle of
that loop you would read from whatever
like happened last on a hardware on one
of your pieces of hardware and you would
update the state of your program the
downside to this is if you wrote a bad
interrupt handler then you could
effectively lock your computer because
if once this is running your keyboard
doesn't get any input other than what
your program does so this would run
forever the next type of programming I
did was in Windows and Windows had a
very small innovation on this which is
that they decided maybe it wasn't a good
idea to give the average programmer
access to the hardware and so they took
over the they took over the the the
processing Hardware messages sorry but
if you look at the actual logic of the
program it's basically the same the same
general deal a loop where you process
messages dispatch them and update state
and the main thing that you would write
as a programmer for a Windows program is
you would write a function that took all
each message and you would take all the
different messages and you use them to
update the state of your program and it
usually looked like a giant switch
statement and so that's the global event
bus and it brings us to about 1999 where
we left the global event bus in the dust
or did we because I don't know if any of
y'all are doing
front-end programming in react recently
but if you look at this and you look at
a for a core logic function that's a
giant switch statement where you take a
message in your update state this
actually looks a lot like a Redux
reducer and Redux actually contains a
lot of the global event bus pattern so
while programming in reacts may be
programming like it's 1999 there are
some good reasons why they went that way
which we'll get to in a second but I
want to talk about the next thing that
we did which is the main pattern in the
main way we've been writing front-end
applications for all of the years since
then and that's something called the
observer pattern so but in order to
explain this because we're going to talk
about the observer pattern a lot I want
to make a very short digression into the
world of influencers so let's say that
you are a very important content creator
you need people to see your content how
do you do this so the old way before the
internet you had to like track people
down and be like please watch my thing
right and it was really terrible but now
we have such such better ways right
because we have this this new contract
which is like I is the contact content
creator and like I'm going to make some
content and you as my adoring fans go on
one of our wonderful scary surveillance
social media platforms and you sign up
and you subscribe to my content and then
when I make new content you get a
notification and you can watch it and
this is basically the observer pattern
in the observer pattern you have a
subject something that essentially
promises it's going to emit events and
an observer who describes an observer
who subscribes to the events and then
can handle them however it wants that's
that's all it is and the fact is and if
you're doing JavaScript programming even
if you're not aware you're probably
using this every day here let's look at
a real example which is let's take the
example of you've got a two elements on
the page one is a toggle switch and the
other is a area that you want to change
the text of when you put the toggle
switch right so here you have a
reference to to the toggle switch that
you've looked up from the dom and then
if you're of a function which will look
up the other element and change its text
so how do you connect these two right
well those of you guys who were done any
JavaScript programming have probably
done something like this you subscribe
to mouse clicks on the toggle switch
making the modify text function into an
observer you could handle and you can
now handle each mouse click by switching
the toggle so that's basically the
observer pattern
so this is at this is really great
because it's a lot simpler and at the
same time it's a much more localized
scope you only have to deal with the
events that you care about right and so
that's a much easier way to do to do
programming now there is a caveat here
which is you've got to set up the
subscriptions and as time goes on you
may find that setting up all the
subscriptions becomes quite complicated
if you have ever tried to implement
drag-and-drop in the browser you
probably with just like Mouse up Mouse
down and mouse over you've probably
found it's quite challenging because in
the middle you basically have to
subscribe to the mouse being clicked
then add a mousemove handler and then
when it's when you lift the mouse you
have to remove that handler so you also
need to be listening to Mouse it's just
very complicated anyway so the problem
here is you're mixing concerns because
you're both handling events and at the
same time you're setting up
subscriptions and by this theory about
how reacts got created which is that the
redux authors were looking at
effectively we're getting tired of the
observer pattern and they looked back
and we're like let's try giving this
global event bus another try but all of
this might be leading you to wonder if
there is a better way and that is the
subject of my talk so this that way in
my opinion is called functional reactive
programming and I'm going to show you
how to write how to use it to write fun
ends like a boss so once upon a time I
was a teacher um I was really bad at
teaching I taught middle school you
should not learn from how I taught
however this is about good teachers and
good teachers are there other have you
ever watched a good teacher teach but
they're kind of like Jedi they have this
way of light a stint interrupts them and
they like kind of like obi-wan the
student back on to the path of the
lesson right it's really amazing and so
how do they do that
well so what what good teachers do is
first of all they have a lesson plan but
they don't use it as a plan they use it
as a guide it's kind
a starting point because if you use it
as a plan you get interrupted very
easily instead you can think of teaching
as essentially a series of planned
responses to interruptions right and
really good teachers know how to not
just respond to interruptions but to
draw out lessons from them to actually
kind of like take the interruption and
turn it and sort of magically fold it
back into the the sort of the key
objectives of the lesson and the in a
good classroom it's almost like a street
a series no matter how it's interrupted
it's like a stream that just keeps
flowing towards the end goal so they
really almost are like Jedi by the way I
highly recommend well I don't know I
highly recommend we ought to be paying
teachers the yeah this my experience
teaching is it's way way harder than
programming I don't know what else so
what have we program like this right
could we write programs is a series of
plan reactions to interruptions what
would that look like well so let's take
a and let's think about this statement y
equals x plus 3 you've probably written
something like this it's in your
programs at some point so in a
traditional imperative program we know
what this means
it means take the current value of X add
3 to it and assign it to the current
value of Y it happens once and then that
assignments done but if you think about
a different context not a not a
programming context let's talk about the
math context in math that statement
actually represents an entire graph it
represents a line expressing a
relationship between x and y and in fact
reactive programming is similar in a
reactive program y equals x plus 3
expresses a relationship between x and y
so that every time X is updated why
would also get updated so you can
imagine X as a stream of data values
that over over the course of time right
and you just imagine new values are
being admitted on that stream
so why
you can also imagine as another stream
where each value is derived from the
values of X and you don't have to just
think about numbers and data you can
think about user events you can imagine
a stream of mouse clicks over time right
so that's the theoretical idea of
reactive programming but how can we
write this into our computers that are
really just executing sequences of
instructions what we need is some kind
of a pattern we need where each value
that changes over time and you could get
notified that it's changing and respond
and if you think about that that sounds
pretty similar to something else that
we've talked about which is the observer
pattern and actually we can use the
observer pattern but we're going to
extend it a little and make it a little
more make it able to do a few more
things so let's introduce the observable
an observable is any value the changes
over time that you can listen for
changes on so let's let's look at how
this works we are out sorry we have an X
and this X is an observable and like an
oblique like in the observer pattern we
can subscribe to it and we can subscribe
and here we're just printing out the
values so you can imagine if you wanted
to print out the values of Y you could
just subscribe to X and then print out
those values plus 3 but what if we
wanted to listen to Y so let's rewind a
bit and think about X as a simple array
if this were an array of numbers and we
wanted to transform this array into the
Y array most languages have a contract
for that in most languages
it's called map right and this would
take X transform each value and give us
the Y array well with observables it's
actually just it's the same thing we
have X as an observable of those same
values and then Y is X map
the difference here and this is a key
difference is that this is a mapping
over time
so as X emits new values and we're
assuming that they're it's going to
continue to emit new values for some
time each value gets transformed and
becomes the current value of Y let's
look at it better let's look at a more
real-world example so this is a let's
say we have two buttons and a ball and
we want to make a ball move between the
two buttons so we have a girl left
button and a girl right button and
basically we want the ball to move when
we click the glow left and the girl
right so the core so how do we do this
with observables well let's say that we
made a stream of our left button clicks
and a right button clicks and so every
time I click the go right button it
would emit on the right button quick
stream and I every time I click the left
button they would have MIT on the left
button stream so you can see that's
pretty basic so now let's say we took
each one of those quick streams we don't
really care there's no value associated
with clip but we could transform the
fact that it happened into a position
right so we could take each quick stream
and turn it into a position stream now
we now if we take these two streams and
we combine them we actually get the
current position of the ball and now we
are emitting the current position of the
ball now I'm using a library to do some
of the animation but that's basically
you know all that all there is to that
how this actually works in code and for
the rest of the talk I'm going to be
showing examples using a really great
observable library called rxjs a
remaining examples are going to be in
JavaScript but they're great rx
libraries in almost every language and
you can apply this to any language or
any context so the first step is so here
we're going to import all various tools
from rxjs and the first step is to look
up our Dom elements once we have the
left button and right button we can use
a function called
event that rxjs provides to convert this
into an observable stream of clicks once
we have those clicks you can see that
here we're just using map to to map the
fact that the click occurred to a
position now rxjs has a slightly
different syntax where you put
everything through this pipe function
but it's basically the same concept
finally we can merge those two streams
with a function called merge that rxjs
also provides and this gives us our
current position we also add one more
thing to this which is an initial
position for the ball and that's
basically it
[Music]
okay so you're excited you drank the
kool-aid 20 minutes in and I'm really
excited actually is 20 minutes in like
it says and now you want to use rxjs
everywhere how do you do this okay so
first of all I want to make a point
which is I was at a talk recently given
by Laurie Voss and he works for NPM and
they have like all of the data on what
packages are getting downloaded so he
had collected data about package
downloads and he was showing this graph
about the react ecosystem and what's
getting downloaded in the react
ecosystem and I saw it and you didn't
mention this but I saw it and I was like
wait what is that what is that line
that's going way way up is that oh my
god it's rxjs and it's more popular than
react itself so so actually I talked to
Lori afterwards and there's there's some
good reasons for this
our XJS is being depended on directly by
several very popular libraries and you
may not be using it yourself but the
lesson here is that the people who write
the libraries that you depend on in
JavaScript are using rxjs okay that's
super cool but what's that you
personally want to use rxjs to use RX
effectively in a real world application
you have two things you need to figure
out one is like how do you actually
architect real
applications using rxjs and second how
do I like integrate rxjs with all the
tools that I know and love so let's look
at a much more real-world example this
is probably something you've implemented
at some point if you've been programming
for a bit a login form right it'll log
in forms are pretty common they kind of
all need the same stuff your login form
needs an entry for like credentials it
needs a way to submit it you probably
want to be able to display some feedback
from the server if you somebody submits
an incorrect login and you may also want
to disable the submit button while the
login is in progress right so um you can
see you know not very exciting you
submit you get an error what else how
could we model this with rxjs so let's
start with three real observables and in
this case we have a user name
representing a stream of everything that
the user types in to the to the username
field and a password field this one's
super secure because you can actually
see what I'm typing and then finally we
have a submit button right so from these
three streams we could actually come up
with a stream of all of our attempts to
login simply by taking an event would
essentially what we need is they would
need to admit whenever the submit button
is clicked and it would need to combine
it with the last thing that the user
typed into the username and password
field once we have attempts we could
kick off a API request to a server and
that would give us a series of responses
once we have both of those we can derive
a bunch of other stuff
we we have login failures and we have
login successes we could filter those
responses and not only that we could
take the time in between when the the
attempt is stream emits and the response
stream emits and we could convert it
into essentially the state of whether
our login is in progress finally we can
take we could convert the successes and
failures into some kind of useful data
in the case of a fair
you're a failure message extracted from
the response from the server and in the
case of a success we might want to get
out of user token and later on we might
take that token and get a bunch of
additional and make a bunch of
additional resources to get maybe some
streams of data of protected resources
that are specific to the user and
effectively oops sorry
did that work you can see that
effectively we could this graph
represents the entire state of our login
program and I'm going to go ahead and
log in correctly now the strange lip is
awesome and you can see that the
passwords are submitting you're getting
oh did I know I probably changed the
password to something I forgot what oh
thank you yeah yeah group the downside
of making these interactive is you could
type the drug anyway you can see that
effectively we've gotten down at the
very bottom that says my stuff we can
imagine that's a protected resource cool
how would you do this in actual code
it's actually not that complicated so
let's take this example and here we have
an API what's this is just a simple like
imagined API it has two endpoints a
login and a protected resource and let's
say and then here let's say these are
our three streams representing our three
user inputs now our extraction struct
these directly from the Dom but in this
case I'm gonna use something called a
subject let's not get into what it is
because I'm gonna show you a better way
to connect these in just a second but
anyway let's say we have these three
primary streams right once we have those
we can just use the combined latest the
WIPP latest from operator that
essentially takes every emission from
the submit button and attaches the
username and password to it that
we could that gives us a stream of
essentially an array of three elements
you can see that I'm sort of like
destructuring it in the call there where
you have and I'm getting the username
and password and then using that to
submit an API requests now the challenge
with an API request is it returns a
promise and you don't really want to
stream up promises you want a stream of
what the promise actually resolves to so
rxjs has an amazing operator called
merge map it's also called flat map in
other languages so you know right don't
get confused on that and that operator
can essentially be used to make the
stream emit not the promises themselves
but what they resolve to once you've got
that the state of state of the login
being a process can be derived
essentially just by merging the attempts
and the responses and converting each
one to a true or false state it's pretty
easy to get the success two separate
login responses into success and
failures because there's just a filter
operator in rxjs and here we're just
filtering on the status that's returned
by the server you can see the failure
works the same way and then once we've
done that we take the response from the
server and we just use some maps to
extract out an error message and
generate that as a text string we could
do the same thing with the user token
and once we have that stream of user
tokens we can start this whole process
over again and use and make another
merge map call to an API oh I see I have
map they're not merge map Oh No yeah
sorry the last one is the using a
different operator called merge all does
the same thing sorry about that
anyway this concept of all of these
signals connected together
you see we seem to of these diagrams and
there's a term for this and call it a
signal graph and the signals are the
emissions from the observables and the
graph is how they're all tied together
this is how we architect programs using
observables our programs become a series
of reactive data streams starting
with the primary signals which are
derived from user inputs and extending
all the way to all the different
derivations we can make based on those
and taken together they form a graph so
where I work we actually program with
observables a fair amount and when we do
and we work on a production application
we actually maintain a graph of all of
our signals in our program this is an
example from an actual production
application that I've worked on now if
you do this in production
you're gonna there's some concerns that
obviously come up you might be wondering
how do I test this how do I test my
signals how do you make sure that my
graph doesn't have cycles of signals
because that presents a whole bunch of
problems or how to make sure that I'm
not depending on signals and art there
are XJS as much as I love it has a
couple in idiosyncrasies Google like hot
and cold observables if you want to go
down that rabbit hole and how do I it'd
be nice to not have to deal with those
one thing that happens in a production
application is the graph gets big and we
have the same sort of ongoing debate
where I work which is like do we
maintain one giant graph or multiple
little graphs and if you have little if
you decide to break it up into little
grass how do you connect those finally
like vacating these diagrams it's work
and like we were like an agile
consultancy we're supposed to like value
working software over documentation so
you know that's a bummer
so basically I recently just was
thinking and I was like orderly take all
these best practices that we've
developed in conversations over like a
couple years of working with observables
and encode them into a library so that
other people could skip these hurdles so
today I just want to talk briefly about
a library that I've published called
signal signal is a library for doing
state management in front-end JavaScript
applications with using signal graphs so
let's take a look at this in the context
of our login example you start in signal
by defining your graph I'm not gonna go
into the very deep
really low-level details of this DSL but
just mostly for time but basically it's
listing all the observables that make up
the graph and how they connect to each
other
primary signals are the inputs and
derived signals are those things that
you can come up with from them in terms
of actually defining the operations that
make up your signals instead of just
defining them directly you define them
as factory functions that go from the
input signals to the output now the nice
thing about this is they're super easy
to test you can just substitute in here
sort of like fake signals for the real
ones another if you want to like hydrate
your graph with an initial state which
is a really common problem you signal
provides this function called initialize
with where you can set the initial
values of all of your signals finally
you just call build and build
essentially takes all that specification
that you've given and builds a signal
graph does nice things for you like
doing topological sort and getting all
your dependencies in order and it will
detect cycles or missing signals so
that's really cool and then one last
super cool thing you can do is you can
connect two graphs together let's say I
have my my first graph was a graph of
all of the things that happen in
authentication one of the last signals
it emits is the status of whether you
are logged in now let's see you have a
separate graph for fetching the sort of
protected resources in the application
and you want to come in and it is gonna
need to start from the status of
authentication and you want to connect
these two well you can just use this
connect function which connects the two
graphs together and you specify which
signals are gonna be tied together and
then essentially they will emit
simultaneously sorry right
Oh right one other thing about this is
that you might be looking at this sort
of like di scheme over here and you're
like that's like kind of old-fashioned
and you're using strings it looks like
angular 1 well if you happen to be using
typescript because I love tight script
there's
they're talking about how much I love
typescript and then you're gonna get
some amazing type bindings in here so
you can't type in anything wrong you
don't have to use typescript but it
makes the experience of using signal
super awesome
so this library is available now
I'm not crimping on my favorite
messengering apps name and that's why
it's under a namespace and the
namespaces are X react which I'm gonna
explain it just a second the caveat is
this is not really production ready yet
I've just been messing around with it
but so play around with me but don't
adopt it in your production applications
just yet one thing that I really want to
do which I haven't been able to do yet
is I believe you could actually auto
generate those diagrams I showed you
earlier you could and I think you could
use that to get some really amazing
debugging insights about like how
signals propagate through your program
the examples I showed you are real they
are interactive I was interacting with
them as I talked to you but I had to
hand create them and I'm still working
on an automatic generation so that
signal lets but you maybe understand
rxjs now is an abstract tool and you
might have an idea of how you're gonna
use it but how do you tie it to like
your good old fashioned JavaScript MVC
framework that you probably use in your
day job so if you happen to be using
angular step one is that you're done
rxjs is integrated in angular and it was
a really good decision I think on the
part of the developers of angular and
there's also some really good tooling
out there but I use react at my job and
I'm like I want to I want to use my
react with my reactive programming and
that's kind of where this talk started
basically I'm a I'm always wanting to
use our XJS in my react applications but
I always end up using Redux because I
work for a consulting company and you
know I can't be that person who saddles
our client developers with you know a
new tool that doesn't a newest
technology that doesn't have great
tooling that they don't necessarily
understand so that's why I've been
working on a lot of tooling for rxjs and
react and so this namespace our x-ray
are the various tools that I built for
integrating rxjs with react now I want
to be clear these are not the only tools
there's a lot of really great stuff out
there but and this is just one operate
offering and I encourage you to check
out the whole ecosystem but I'm gonna
show you this is the one I'm going to
show you so there you go so the simplest
toy I've made is a tool called signal
connect and this is basically if you're
using a signal library and you want to
connect your signal grass to react
components you use this thing called
signal connect oh my god and I messed up
something in here okay well that's okay
so let's go back to our earlier example
of the position tube all right and this
here is a react component that
represents our ball it's a really simple
react component it takes a position a
single property which is the position
and it essentially just moves that ball
to whatever position you specify it's
using that react animation library to do
this sort of smooth moving back and
forth so let's say we've now built a
signal graph using signal that
represents the one that I showed you
earlier that where we use the the clicks
on the left and right button to derive
the position of the ball what we're
going to do and I put me wrong so an
easy to imagine this the text it says
with view model reads connect this is
the downside of finishing your slides
ten minutes before you're gonna import a
function called connect from signal
connect and this function works a lot
like if you've used react Redux it works
a lot like that you're gonna pass it the
signal graph and two parameters or in a
simple case just one the first parameter
represents the outputs of the signal
graph right these and and the keys in
the object you pass here become props on
the component that are auto updated from
outputs on the signal graph in this case
we are tying the position prop to the
position signal in the signal graph
and that's basically it that will move
that essentially every time the position
signal emits the ball will get a new
prop for its position so that's getting
data out of the graph what about when
you want to take user events and connect
them back into the graph in this case
that's what the separate second
parameter is for in the second parameter
each property it becomes a function
because you want to be in it in the
context of a react component you're
gonna need to call a function to
essentially send data back out becomes a
function that you can that when you call
wherever you pass that function will get
emitted on the signal you specify in the
signal graph in this case it's the we're
taking the on quick handler for the left
button and we are connecting it to the
left click signal and so basically every
time a quick occurs the left click
signal will admit that it occurred
inside the signal graph and you can
actually pass it data so if you're you
doing the sort of logging example you
could pass in the username and and
password now I want to show I was hoping
that that was gonna come up a little
higher oh well this is actually a real
example of the entire login component
and although you cannot see most of it
uh that's too bad it actually is there's
basically like seven signals you extract
out of the graph and that completely
connects up an entire login form
component it's pretty cool oh there we
go
yeah wait no hold on okay cool we're at
the last part of the talk the I call
this the user used car sales portion
because this is where I show you all the
other things I've written very quickly
it's also the part where like my notes
get a little thin and you know so here
we go all right first of all let's say
you don't really you're like I don't
want to buy your signal graph Hannah you
don't buy it it's free it's open source
sorry that's a little awkward I'm not
Hawking anything but you want to you
don't want to use the signal graph
library you just
Connect react rxjs well actually the
first library that I wrote was a library
to do that um it's actually a little
more stable and the syntax is pretty
similar you use this function called
with view model you define you know
here's your box component you define
essentially inputs to the component in a
thing that it's called a view model this
is this was originally architected from
some programming I did an Rx swift and
an Rx with you defined these sort of
like view models to provide data that
back your components and in this case
each input is an observable that becomes
a prop you import this function from rx
react and then you just call it it's it
basically operates the same way the
difference here is you're just manually
injecting your observables same thing
happens for outputs and that's and this
is an example of the complete graph cool
all right what about typescript right so
like let's say you are super concerned
about like the stability instruction
your program you you know really care
you know so you want to bring introduced
static typing well the good news is all
these tools are written in typescript I
kind of loved typescript as I said and
there's really strong Taipings across
the board to help you sort of prevent
using these libraries incorrectly or
just introducing errors into your
program let's say you love reducers
because everybody loves a reducer and
you've been using Aria redux a lot and
you want to back your component with a
reducer um well I've been working on an
experiment of just doing of essentially
modeling a reducer with signals and and
this is a function called with view
model from reducer which will where you
pass it an initial state and a reducer
and then you can connect it to your
component and effectively you get the
syntax that's very similar to if anyone
is used reason to react a reason Emma in
reason ml which is Facebook's super new
language it's I basically modeled the
syntax after that
that's rx react reducer and those are
all the that's all I have from a talk
thanks very much the slides are up there
they're a little out of date but I will
be up to
updating them soon
[Applause]